a new school in a new place this first
day is both exciting and daunting for
arena misschenko about to turn six
I was going to the kindergarten before
she tells us then the war came that's
when she and her family sheltered in the
basement
I want to learn my letters and numbers I
don't know them very well yet and my
grandmother has been helping me
everything is new because almost
everything she and her family owned was
left behind in the southern region of
Carson
I always dreamed that she would attend
the same school as I did in our home
Village you always want the best for
your child
instead her new school will be north of
Kiev where work continues repairing
buildings that were damaged in the
initial Invasion and which are now
dealing with an influx of children from
the fighting in the South and the East
but dear friends I've changed the
teachers have changed their environment
has changed so there's a huge mental
pressure on those children
and for their teachers there's the added
burden of creating timetables according
to the size of their shelters for
example there are schools which are okay
to register like 15 and the children but
the shelter capacitors on there for 300
children so 300 children come at a time
to the school
estimates vary but it's reckoned as many
as 3 000 schools have been damaged or
completely destroyed since the start of
the war and in the last Academic Year
only about a quarter of Ukrainian
schools were able to offer full-time
in-person learning this is all that's
left of 12 year old Sophia fedachenko's
home Village in the south
and this was the school she attended as
she and her family adjust to a New Life
she was super
school by the time we were able to leave
the school year was almost over
for severe and thousands of other
displaced children the priority on this
first day of school making up for lost
time
Rob McBride Al Jazeera European Ukraine
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera